So here's something to think about.
This is a way of approaching
what Rogers was up to.
Imagine how you use words.
No,
you could use words instrumentally.
Let's start with that.
If imagine that you want something
from someone and then you might think,
well,
how can I phrase my argument so that
I'm going to get that from this person?
And then you might say,
well,
what sort of argument would appeal to
that person and what buttons can I push
and how can I get what I want?
And then you're using words
in an instrumental way.
You're using them as tools to obtain
what you desire from other people.
Now,
I think if you do that completely,
you're a psychopath.
I mean that because a psychopath
has no room for you at all.
It's about him or her and you're there
to be used as an instrumental target.
Now,
I'm not saying that every time
someone uses language instrumentally,
they're acting like a psychopath,
but
that's the logical conclusion
to that form of language use.
Now then you might think,
well,
you can ask little kids tried
to do that to their parents,
right?
Siblings will often collude,
we'll have a little
conspiratorial conversation
about how to approach one parent
or the other.
Usually by isolating the parents,
that's a good strategy.
And then they'll phrase their requests
so that they can extract out the desired
benefit.
Um,
I follow these pickup artists online,
um,
being very interested in
their use of psychology.
And they are instrumental language users,
right?
So their trick is they're
developing a whole little hope,
hurry of verbal tricks that
they use in attempts to seduce.
It's a very narrow focus and
it's instrumental language.
It,
it's as if that the personhood of the,
of the target is irrelevant fundamentally.
So it's a fairly pathological,
it can become pathological,
very easy.
So then you might say,
well,
how would you use language if
you weren't using instrumentally?
Because you know,
you have to have a career and
you have to be goal oriented.
You have to be aimed towards things.
And so since you have to be goal oriented,
how can it be other than that,
you would use language instrumental.